hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to new portion of the show
called old versus new
[Music]
[Applause]
this is where I take something old and
nostalgic and compare it to a recent
remake to find out which one is better
with that said let's take a look at two
of my favorite movies of all time Batman
and The Dark Knight
now both these films push the envelope
of how to make a comic book movie they
were dark edgy and constantly breaking
the barrier between fun Kitty antics and
epic adult dilemmas but which one is
truly better the original for the
reimagining now I know technically
Batman Begins was the first of these new
movies but Dark Knight is concerned the
best and it has the most similarities to
the 89 film battling the Joker and so
forth
also remember that none of this is fact
as quickly opinion so don't go apeshit
if you don't agree with me even if you
are completely wrong so let's see who is
the best bad as we compare Batman
[Music]
well let's just cut to the chase and
jump to the main character Michael
Keaton versus Christian Bale
well to be fair Christian Bale has a lot
to act he has to play Bruce Wayne the
college doing Bruce Wayne the outcast
Bruce Wayne the warrior Bruce Wayne the
drunken millionaire and Bruce Wayne is
Batman thank God they didn't ask him to
do Bruce Wayne the transvestite that
would destroy any one of those would be
hard to do and he has to do all five but
I have to admit as hard as Bale tries
Michael Keaton is still the superior
Batman
the main reason he keeps all his pain
inside when you see the bail you can
instantly see someone who's either
looking for attention or trying to hide
something with Keaton
he acknowledges that this is his Bandol
and he'll fight it alone if you've heard
this guy was Batman you'd be like yeah
he seemed a little odd to me
but with Keaton you totally wouldn't
believe it in fact a lot of people
didn't many petition not to have Kim as
Batman because they couldn't see him in
the role but that's why he's so freaking
perfect you wouldn't suspect him look at
Lee grieves over his parents death this
is all very very subtle no tears no
facial expressions but you can feel the
pain that he's going through where bail
still seemed a little lost and confused
and of course you have to look at them
as Batman he is the only Batman who can
actually smile and still look
intimidating it says yeah I got nothing
to fear bitch your ass is grass
bailed on the costume just looks well
silly not to be fair that has a lot to
do with the design Keaton's costume was
dynamic classy but also very threatening
bands always look a little off to me the
nose was weird and I think it was a
little too bulky it didn't look like
Batman it looks like a guy dressing on
this Batman and of course there's that
infamous voice yes shitty
just showed you that it's full of people
ready to believe it good I know
everyone's made fun of this boy so I'm
trying to keep it to a minimum let's
just say Keaton's sounded very natural
The Joker's tended hundreds of chemicals
at the source and bales a hero to
Florida to see yourself the villain
didn't affect let's play these right
scenes back to back I'm not going to
kill you I want you to do me a favor
I want you to tell all your friends
about me where were the other drugs
going why you can tell Bale is trying to
be threatening while King just sort of
naturally is yeah you don't mess with
mr. mom even what he's trying to save a
family's life he still does that stupid
voice you don't want to hurt the boy
army come on people's lives are at stake
can you just cut the act because you
were the best Amish just crazy doesn't
read it ain't orbit which is anytime
soon good night moon good night moon
good night star while still doing a good
job bail can't compete with the
unexpected master himself point goes to
keep sorry to disappoint
[Music]
but a hero can only be as good as his
villain and the Joker is one of the
greatest villains of all time but again
which one is the true Clown Prince of
Crime ledger or nickels
I have to admit when I heard he Fletcher
was going to play the choker I said what
a pussy guy from a Knight's Tale come on
and when I saw the design of the
character that didn't help much either
it looked like a kid who put on
grandma's makeup how is that right even
after his tragic death I didn't change
anything for me I still thought he was
gonna suck nobody can top Jack and
nobody ever will
he's practically been playing the damned
hard all his life so what makes them
think this pretty boy can do any better
well thankfully I was 100% Heath Ledger
is not only funniest the Joker but he's
also shit your pants scary I think this
is because he encompassed every previous
Joker that had existed before the comic
the cartoon the Nicholson performance
there's even a little bit of Cesar
Romero in there just listen to that
laugh and tell me they don't sound alike
but while combining all the previous
Joker's together he also managed to
still stay fresh and new paying allies
to the other renditions but still giving
his own take as well
Nicholson is great and funny but he's
more creepy than is scary linter was
actually terrified and this is the scene
I think cemented it for everybody
he was so scary you could hear a pin
drop after this moment was over every
day he doesn't people will die starting
tonight I'm a man of my word
it's interesting how in the 89 film we
know all about the Joker and little
about Batman yet in the new films we
know all about Batman and little about
the Joker in both cases I say less is
more the more mystery there is about the
character the more fascinating we often
find them and Ledger's character is no
exception
jackal um BIA but this is the Joker that
seems to have everything all the laughs
all the intelligence and all the
freights I have given a name to my pain
but what good is good characters without
good supporting characters I don't know
but this film had some good ones
this isn't quite as easy to pick out
because both films had a really good
cast
I guess we'll look at girlfriends first
Kim Basinger versus Maggie Gyllenhaal 5
Katie Holmes now believe it or not I
actually didn't mind Katie Holmes in
Batman Begins true it looks like she's
about 12 but outside of that I think she
did all right and the same can be said
for Gyllenhaal who both played very
tough and intelligent roles basing her
on the other hand was a very difficult
damsel in distress always in trouble
always being safe and I swear speaking
alien screams but to be fair she was a
much more interesting character she was
kind insightful I was also coming and
quick she was supportive but also had
her limits which made her seem a lot
more realistic she really stood out as a
character when the other two just seem
to stand out as role models that isn't
bad it's just not very memorable
Alfred is also kinder in this movie but
I have to met I love how anxious and
involved Kane gets a new belt but do
does he always have a speech prepared
Batman stands for something more
important but you spat in the faces of
Gotham's criminals he squeezed them you
hammered him to the point of desperation
that's the point of Batman he can make
the choice that no one else can make
good god he can give a speech about
anything
hey offering you want some breakfast a
long time ago I was in Burma my friends
and I were working for the local
government they were trying to buy the
Lord out of tribal leaders by bribing
them with precious stones I just want to
know if you want Pat Hingle was good as
Commissioner Gordon but Gary Oldman is
always a powerhouse actor giving even a
small supporting role so much weight
though maybe he just relates with people
that dress up like giant bats I can't
imagine why and I guess there's really
no point in comparing Harvey Dent's as
the first don't barely mentions him and
eventually turns into yeah but overall I
think I have to go with the 89 Phil why
because god damn it it heads Bob in it
and I fucking love Bob he's the henchman
that doesn't say anything do anything
but for some reason he really leaves an
impression
he's like the Bubba Fett of Batman he
barely does anything but
some reason people just love it he even
got his own action figure why why the
fuck does he have his own action figure
I don't know I don't care I just know
that little bit of coolness tips the
pile over the Batman side I love you Bob
we all do but hey look father good
supporting characters that they can't
beat the shit out of each other here's
to the best actions
monkeys felt a really good action but
all in this that fat man's is a little
more traditional I mean the sins are
great and the fighting is cool but it's
really spectacular I mean look at this
they fire randomly in the air why isn't
that waste of ammo well they're looking
for birds to shoot or something
despite Batman Begins suffering from way
too much shaky-cam Dark Knight learned
it's lesson gave us some really intense
action scenes the best one being the car
chase in the middle of the film this was
really hardcore had a great amount
suspense intentions the rest of the
action is decent to the last fight at
the end it seemed to go on a bit yeah
you can see what's grandeur in Dark
Knight where the grandness of all the
other films is somewhat limited to its
effects budget yeah that doesn't look
like a mono at all
again I love the action in both films
but Dark Knight had you glued to it
scenes from beginning down and I'd say
they definitely deserve
so now it all comes down to the most
important factor of all the story which
one was best written best directed but
just overall best told well let's dig in
a little closer to find out
now to be fair the plots of both these
films is all over the family knew them
are that coherent but then again with
the Joker that's kind of the idea the
motivation of Ledger's Joker seems to be
to spread anarchy and chaos but
Nicholson's motivation actually is
anarchy and chaos
it just sounds crazy I make art to
someone how totally nuts is that that's
like saying I want to be an architect
I need bodies the bill also climbs to a
decent climax building on top of every
scene while still leaving time for the
audience to breathe in dark night the
whole third act is like one big climax
it's intense but it does get a little
tiring after a while get there it would
be a break alright gimme a minute eh any
water in the 89 film a lot of people had
problems with bad night be so quieter
than the shadows love Joker is so loud
and soaks up the attention but really
that's what's so brilliant about it
Batman
is mysterious and he is quiet that's
what makes him so fascinating and that's
really my main problem with the Dark
Knight they analyse everything in Batman
all the choices dilemmas and
consequences are implied and hinted at
the rest you can just see from how the
characters look in their actions that's
the idea of a visual medium that's
really only one talk about life a man
does what he does and it seems very much
like how a real prison would talk look
sometimes I don't know what to think
about this it's just something I have to
do why because nobody else can in Dark
Knight everything is talked about and I
mean everything when the chips are down
these are these civilized people they'll
eat each other don't question me about
ethical dilemmas too I read psychology
for dummies - it's like if the
characters of Greek mythology actually
talked about and analyzed their problems
all the time it wouldn't be the same
it's not their place to talk about it
that's the job of a viewer the 89 Batman
will be talked a little but said a lot
the dilemmas are still very interesting
nice to them and don't get me wrong I
love the talks of the dark night but
they seem like conversations that movie
craves would have not be active
characters so like I said before the
plot is kind of a big decided point here
so which one do I like better well as
much as I love the Dark Knight I have to
say Batman is the one that's more
compact it just seems like a more
classic story or somewhat more epic
I love the themes of the Dark Knight how
adult they make the protagonist but it
just seems more like a character study
that does an actual a three-act movie so
even though I love both films and I'll
probably get a lot hate mail for this I
have to say that Batman is the superior
film
[Music]
so the old wins in this situation does
that mean I don't like the dark night
not at all I just like Batman a little
more and my hope is that Christian Bale
doesn't take what I said about it too
seriously
hello the fuck are you doing I'm sorry
man I just thought don't just be sorry
think for one fucking second well that's
not very nice what the fuck is it with
you are you professional or not well I
don't like to brag oh I hate man your
amateur look the fuck up no no fucking
kick your fucking ass why so angry I
just don't get it
what don't you get about it oh hello
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't make a fuckin
air I just don't get why you made Batman
sound like you get lung cancer oh good
for you
you're a nice guy I think you got the
fuck a little shut up
go make great a fire - no yeah no yeah
fuck's sake